Welcome back.
Before I move onto the next
problem, sometimes I rush near
the end of the video just
because I want to get under
the YouTube 10-minute limit.
But I just want to make sure you
understand the conclusions
I reached in this problem
because it's kind of
interesting.
If I have a bunch of numbers and
when I multiply them I get
a non-zero number, I know none
of these numbers can be 0,
because as you know, if any
one of them was 0 or maybe
more than one, then this
value would be 0.
So we know none of these
can be 0, rst or v.
And similarly, between stu and
v-- let me re-write that, stu
and v equals 0-- we know that at
least one of these must be
0 because when you multiply
it out you get 0.
Maybe all of them are.
Well we know s is not 0 because
it was up here.
We knew t was not 0 and we knew
v were not 0 because they
were all up on this top one.
And if any of them were
0, this top equation
would have been 0.
And that's how we reached
that conclusion.
So let's move on.
I hope I'm not confusing you.
I'm doing it with a bit of a
sense of urgency just because,
well I guess one should
when taking the SAT.
All right, number 8.
During a game the blue team
scored 1/6 of its-- so let me
do the blue team in blue.
The blue team scored
1/6 of its points
in the first quarter.
So Q1 they scored
1/6 of points.
1/4 in the second quarter.
So in Q2 scored 1/4
of its points.
1/3 in the third quarter.
So in Q3 they scored
1/3 of its points.
1/3 in the third quarter, and
remaining points in the fourth
quarter, which makes sense.
If the total score was 36, how
many points did the blue team
score in the fourth quarter?
Well the total points
are 36, right?
So it says they scored 1/6
in the first quarter.
So 1/6 of 36-- you could do that
in your head or you could
just multiply fractions.
If you say 1/6 times 36.
That equals 36 over
6, which equals 6.
So they scored 6 points
in the first quarter.
How many did they score
in the second quarter?
Well what's 1/4 of 36.
So you just multiply 1/4
times 36 and you get 9.
1/3 of 36, well that's 12.
So in the first three quarters
we scored what?
6 plus 9 is 15.
15 plus 12 is 27.
So we scored 27 in the first
three quarters, right?
And then we scored
the rest in Q4.
So it would be the total points
minus what we scored in
the first three quarters,
which is 27.
And 36 minus 27 is 9 points.
And if I look at the choices,
that is choice C.
And if I made a mistake it's
because I cannot add, subtract
or multiply fractions.
But that's all there
is to this problem.
Let's move on.
Sometimes I feel like I'm going
too fast, so I want to
make sure I'm not
confusing you.
I like these type because
I don't have to
write a lot or draw.
Well I like the drawing,
it just takes time.
I will switch colors to keep
you from sleeping.
2 to the 2x-- this is
problem number 9.
2 to the 2x is equal to
8 to the x minus 1.
They just want to
know, what is x?
So at first you might
be confused.
But the trick to doing these
kind of exponential-- I guess
we can call them an exponential
equation-- is to
get our bases the same.
And once we get the bases the
same then we can set the
exponents equal to each other.
So how do I do that?
Well can I write 8
as a power of 2?
Well sure, what's 8?
It's 2 to the third power.
So let's rewrite 8 as 2
to the third power.
So let's figure out
the whole thing.
2 to the 2x is equal to--
instead of 8, I'm going to
write 2 to the third power.
Because that's all 8 is.
And hopefully you can review
the exponent video if you
don't remember that.
And this 8 is this, and then
that's going to the x minus 1.
And then if you remember your
exponent rules, and you should
remember your exponent rules
before taking the SAT, you
know that if you raise something
to a power and then
raise that to a power,
you can just
multiply these two exponents.
So that gets us to 2 to the 2x
is equal to 2 to the 3 times x
minus 1, right, and you
distribute the 3.
So it's 2 to the 3x minus 3.
3 times x, 3 times minus 1.
3x minus 3.
Now 2 to the 2x is equal to 2 to
the 3x minus 3, so we know
that the two exponents must be
equal to each other because we
have the same base.
Now this becomes a level one
linear equations problem.
2x is equal to 3x minus 3.
We can subtract 3x from both
sides and we get minus x is
equal to minus 3, or
x is equal to 3.
And we are done.
And this is choice number B.
Turning the page, number 10.
If 4 less-- I like these-- If 4
less than 3 times a certain
number is 2 more than the
number, what is the number?
So this is literally turning
English into math.
So I'm going to actually
write the whole thing.
Not that you should do this on
the SAT because it'll take you
too much time.
But you can do this kind of
with their written word.
If 4 less than 3 times a certain
number is 2 more than
the number, what
is the number?
So instead of a certain number I
like to replace that with x,
just because I'm going to
have to solve for x.
So I'm going to change
this and I'm going
to say this is x.
What is x-- more than
the number x.
So now we have if 4 less than
3 times x is 2 more than x,
what is the number?
So what is 4 less
than 3 times x?
Well 3 times x is what?
It's 3x.
3 times x-- so if I took this
part, 3 times x, that's 3x.
And then 4 less than that
is going to be minus 4.
And that is, and I view is-- you
could view that as equals.
You could have replaced the
word equals with is and it
wouldn't have changed the
meaning of the sentence.
So that equals 2 more than the
number, or in our case, x.
So what is 2 more than x?
It's x plus 2.
2 more than x, you could just
rewrite in math as x plus 2.
And then we solve
the equation.
So let's see, you could add 4
to both sides, you get 3x is
equal to x plus 6.
Subtract x from both sides.
You get 2x is equal to 6.
And divide both sides by 2, and
you get x is equal to 3.
And there we go,
it's choice E.
I will stop this video
here because the next
one involves drawing.
I don't want to draw
on your time.
I'll see you soon.